[Music]
[Applause]
and i've been set a challenge from a
fellow chair to um have this meeting
done in 35 minutes so um
we we'd bet we'd better start and
seeing it's one o'clock i'll call the
last meeting in 2020
of the district plan and regulation
committee to order
and i appear to have no apologies
that would be correct look at it
that's my brief you stole it no i've
still in it there we go
cool are there any conflicts of interest
that
anyone would like to declare appear to
be none
confirmation of minutes from the 20th of
october
thank you everyone has read the minutes
anyone have any additions or corrections
or would like to move council mailings
moves
council reckons in seconds no discussion
any
uh oh yeah uh councillor duty
sorry there's no name tags i can't see
the name oh you've turned yours around
sorry
you were there and you're not recorded
oh indeed
thank you are you in the attendance
because at that point you weren't part
of the committee is that right
okay well we'll so we can get that
rectified
thank you other thank you councillor
the movers are happy with that thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against i declare that carried
um any matters arising appear to be none
we have no deputations today so move on
to 6.1
which is adopting the council plan
change for some of the retirement
villages
sam and matt to the table
one alter
good afternoon councillors i would take
the report
for determining an operative date for
the private plan change 29 somerset
villages ring your limited as read
i do however point to section 2c
which requires correction as it should
state the 16th of january 2021
and not 2020
as stated in section 3.5 a resource
consent has been lodged for retirement
village as a discretionary activity
and for particular interest 65 car parks
20 for staff and 45 for visitors has
been provided
with a total of 564 car parks for the
village
which i note is above the threshold
provided within our district plan
i welcome any questions and thank you
any questions from the team just one
quickly from me
sam i've read through the decision but i
just wondered if you could give a
quick summary summary of any additional
conditions that were put onto the
resource consent
so in terms of the plan change it was
adopted but it had a couple of things
that needed to be amended
and for one there was a missing rule in
terms of espionage
um consequential numbering changes that
occurred
and there was sorry um
there was some other bits and pieces in
terms of wording that needed to be
clarified
but otherwise for the most part it was
how it was presented to us
thank you is there anyone who'd be
prepared to move or any further
questions
counselor mailings sorry
i wouldn't ask one question so i note
that
there was discussion obviously with
regard to the nps ud
and the
outcome that we got out of this was that
we did get them to provide some car
parks
so if this was under our old district
planning
under the operative district plan
without the nps ud how would that have
compared
they wouldn't breach any rule that
provided above the threshold
brilliant thank you i'm prepared to move
there's no meetings there's moving
councillor atkinson seconding
counselor meanings would you like to
speak
um look this looks like it's
looks to be a rather thorough process
that's gone through
they've worked through issues and have
gone above and beyond what they had to
do
and this is a facility that we need
in our district and we need in
this area and i'm sure that it will
provide
some great housing options for elderly
going forward
and some good employment prospects so um
bring it on councillor atkinson
any further speakers no this appeared to
be none i'll put the motion as it is
with that slight correction to see to
all those in favor please say aye
against
declare that carried thank you very much
sam
right moving on to portfolio updates
and district plan i don't think there's
anything that needs to be said we've
been working very very hard but i do
want to thank
the entire committee and everyone who's
participated in that exercise
it's been a very very thorough exercise
to get it to the point we've got it now
and i'm looking forward to working on
the
um adoption of the draft and the
notification
in 2021 and councilor emily do you have
anything to add
thank you councillor redmond regulation
civil defence
thank you madam chair um
three or four areas i'll comment on the
first one is planning
the ravenswood plan change has been
notified
and 70 submissions received
and that's seeking to re-zone about 13
hectares of land to business one
where it's currently his own residential
6a and business one zones
a hearing is scheduled for probably some
time after march next year
the summerset plan change has just been
made operative
in 2021 not 2020
target racecourse quarry application
this is a joint matter with ecan who
will hear submissions
for the discharge consent application
405 submissions have been received
and are currently being processed it's
likely the hearing will be well into
2021.
there's a proposal for a 70 villa
development between pentecost and
townsend roads
just south of the new school the
development look
like it's aimed at retirement in their
retirement audience
the lime living consent is almost ready
to go to the commissioner addressing his
final concerns the last point is
interpretation of a small amount of
short duration shading on a neighbour
building control building activities
picked up
the team members have now been pulled
back from selwyn
to help with the workload this year's
budget was set on a conservative
estimate of 520 new dwellings
and it looks like it'll be closer to
580.
um much closer to the pre-covet covert
mid-600 level
the bca
two yearly accreditation is scheduled
for june next year
so the team is having an independent
audit in february to tease out any
matter
before that occurs the environmental
services unit
dogs 88 infringement notices have been
issued at 300
each for unregistered dogs
alcohol the wood in bottle shop where a
pizza takeaway is proposed to be changed
to a bottle store
the chair of the committee has issued a
minute
explaining the timeline and the reasons
for delay
there was an outstanding report due from
the medical officer of health which has
been received
and a hearing can now be set no earlier
than march next year
so it's fairly drawn out process the big
daddy's
application in rangyora is still to be
set for a hearing
and the reasons for these delays in
particular are that the government has
extended
the covert order that pushed out
reporting times for the ministry of
health and police
until this month so it's unlikely any
hearings well we're almost at the end of
the year will be um
heard this year so we'll have some of
those next year
uh civil defence uh the cadet awards are
tonight
with awards for leadership in the top
cadet
and uh mia dan will be presenting
that starts at 6 15 tonight
at the dudley pool um a cadet camp at
glen tui occurred at the end of november
included with this were some nima long
service awards to volunteers
with heather thomas receiving
recognition for 40 years service
duncan lundy for 30 years service
and there were five who received 10
years award
10-year service awards and
i think kirsten may have received an
award as well
the previous one the previous one sorry
anyhow the mayor and kirsten attended
kirsten is a volunteer
and there was an afa presentation in
oxford which was
obviously well attended af8
which was attended by over 120 people so
that was obviously very successful
i have some statistics about gambling in
the district but i understand that's
going to be the subject of a further
report at some stage
so um that's it from me thank you
are there any questions on that report
to be none thank you very much for that
report um 7.3 that portfolio report's
been moved to the council meeting
and i have no questions i have no urgent
general business
uh just before closing the meeting today
i'd like to recognize that it's nick
harrison's final
dpnr meeting today and i want to thank
you very much
nick for all your sage advice and for
your
help through the years with all the
matters in district plan and before that
in esu
you've served us very very well in in
the council and we will miss you as part
of dpnr so i'd like to
offer a round of applause for mr
[Applause]
harrison
[Laughter]
just briefly um we've had the
opportunity to
say a few words just last week because
we had a handover to of controllers but
to just i'd like to share with those
comments
that you've done a very fine job working
for us over these number of years
and the particularly difficult area of
council the regulatory side where you're
having to tell people
that i can't do things is never easy i
think you've always dealt
with people really well and i showed
real technical competence and the advice
that you've given us
over that time as well and your many um
uh hats that you've worn through that
time so just to thank you for your
service
we will miss you and wish you and shona
well
um with the future but also recognising
that for the civil defense role you've
also held for last i think it's ten
years
um which we acknowledged on on friday
with that hand over to matt so
thanks nick for all that you've done we
really appreciate it and also oxford the
hoka community board you've served and
um there is in the advisor role in
recent months too
so appreciated what you've done there
thank you madam chair
thank you very much nick right with that
i will declare the meeting close and
thank you for your attendance
[Music]
[Laughter]
but now we but now we have a briefing
yeah of course but wait there's more